electrophilic aromatic substitution can
be used to introduce a nitro group onto
an aromatic ring the Nitro group is an
interesting functional group because no
matter how we draw the lewis structure
we cannot avoid having formal charges on
it now if we just focus on the extra
electron pair that's making the formal
negative charge on this single bonded
oxygen we can actually represent this as
the negative charge and then see how the
movement of this electron pair to make a
new double bond here can push electrons
on to the other oxygen giving it the
formal negative charge we can show our D
localization a bit better by showing
this representation however this is not
convenient for showing arrow pushing in
the nitration reaction benzene can be
reacted with a mixture of sulfuric and
nitric acid to form nitro benzene the
mechanism begins with nitric and
sulfuric acid reacting to form the
nitronium ion in the first step the
stronger acid protonates
the weaker acid but wait a second nitric
and sulfuric acid are both strong acids
so how can we tell which is stronger
well we can look at a PKA table and see
that nitric acid has a pKa of minus 1.3
and sulfuric acid has a pKa of negative
3.0 but we can also look at stabilizing
effects of the conjugate bases remember
when the conjugate base of any acid is
more stabilized the compound is more
likely to give up a proton because it
has stabilization when that proton is
gone let's take a moment to look at the
resonance forms of nitric and sulfuric
acid and see if we can rationalize
sulfuric acid being the stronger acid we
can show the localization in the
conjugate base of nitric acid by pushing
electrons from the oxygen anion through
the double bonded oxygen this gives us a
total of three resonance forms for the
conjugate base of nitric acid now let's
look at the conjugate base of sulfuric
acid here we're just showing the first
proton coming off because that is the
one that ionizes completely
second one does not in each of these
forms we're going to maintain six bonds
to sulfur but we're going to push
electrons so that we have our oxy anion
forming sulfur oxygen double bonds we
can see for the conjugate base of
sulfuric acid we also have three
resonance forms so what's the difference
why is sulfuric acid a stronger acid in
the conjugate base of sulfuric acid we
actually have another effect going on
this inductive electron withdrawing
effect further stabilizes the negative
charge in the conjugate base of sulfuric
acid making this more stabilized and
thus a stronger acid returning to our
mechanism we can now show nitric acid
getting protonated by sulfuric acid if
we protonate the oxygen containing the
hydrogen atom this will make water which
is a good leaving group so the product
of this step is a protonated form of
nitric acid and the conjugate base of
sulfuric acid which we looked at in
detail below now we have two formal
positive charges next to each other in
this molecule so we want to relieve this
repulsive force and break off water
however if we just made water leave we
would end up with a two plus charge on
nitrogen which isn't very favorable at
all fortunately we have that oxy anion
right next door that can push down its
electrons assisting in the departure of
the leading group and leaving nitrogen
with just a plus one charge elimination
of the leading group gives the nitronium
ion and a molecule of water
now the nitronium ion is a powerful
electrophile and so benzene will open up
its double bond and attack it now we
have a carbo cation on benzene that
needs to be neutralized it can be
neutralized by the deprotonation of this
hydrogen atom now in this mechanism it
might be tempting to take the conjugate
base of sulfuric acid to do this
deprotonation however remember how
resonance stabilized that was from above
it's not going to be a very good
nucleophile because it's electrons are
tied up in all that resonance and that
inductive
so there's a better nucleophile a better
base in the solution that we can use for
the deprotonation notice we made a
molecule of water above all so even the
most concentrated acids have a
significant amount of water in them so
water is a much better base to use in
this deprotonation and gives us
nitrobenzene plus a molecule of
hydronium ion